hello everybody and welcome to part 4 of
let's play penumbra the Black Plague
I have to apologize in the past few
videos the vol I forgot to turn the
volume down so you could barely hear me
but I mean you can still hear me when
I'm yelling but sometimes when I'm quiet
it goes out but anyway that's the way it
goes sometimes I made a mistake and it
was dumb
alright anyway just unlock this door
here the super secret code that I
guessed on the first try
oh yeah here bag 10 kilograms oh it oh
it ain't no thing
alright whatever box some behind the box
obviously yeah wasn't even a question
Oh going down doing a dark scary hole
not even a little bit scary we got here
uh-huh
what Oh sewer I wouldn't be a horror
game without some sewer oh we got here
yeah get out here oh the sewers seemed
like the only route out but uh whatever
Oh a word ready for a worm oh yeah
batteries these tunnels seemed perfectly
suited for a worm type creature oh
that's cool
well yeah here let's see I love these
wheels oh yeah oh they're so intuitive
Oh oh yeah Oh leap box jumping skills
I'll get ready guys this is gonna be so
awesome oh oh yeah
get what
[Music]
ah what the hell
oh come on John it wasn't that bad
jeez you're such a pansy you pass out of
the earliest signal alright what's going
on Paul oh I remember this is the
beginning of overture uh-huh yeah I have
been this place
oh I let me repeat what I did let's hear
me oh let's see
Oh Jake annual oh don't need that huh a
barrel oh the mouse oh I can't figure it
out Oh a log I smash it with my face Oh
a can of soup this was up here before
Oh what's this a bag I can move this
back before that's a lie Oh what if
something in my inventory oh I don't
know oh no no Oh a key who's he no key
this time okay there's a flashlight
there oh oh oh I get it something's
missing
uh-huh what's what's missing what give a
bucket where this bucket come from Oh
uh-huh
uh-huh oh yeah what's up with that huh
can't fool me what's in here a head oh
oh I get it I get it make it like the
picture there we go let's see there we
go
come here come up turn you oh I'm gonna
I swear to God oh you are I hate you
okay yep yep just like the picture
uh-huh okay lock just phenomenal
yeah oh yeah couldn't move that before
pictures drawer door that can open up
top nothing lamp swinging swinging jaw
okay all right
say can I open it now nope still locked
okay well I am now lost
the hell
come on all right what have I got I got
alcohol glow stick syringe
shut up John unasked you oh well I guess
I needed that alcohol
shut up I know exactly what I'm thinking
well I put it like the picture I don't
know what it wants from me see a barrel
bucket wasn't there huh all right
I had an eyeball ah oh yeah oh that's
hard to see okay I get it I get it I get
it
oh yeah you tried to barrels in it huh
oh so smart all so smart okay all right
soup can all the soup can yeah
Oh soup can condense you can't okay oh
yeah oh I'm the best oh shut up okay huh
what is this why the hell Oh much
creepier what the hell is this two hands
oh it's creepy
it kept artwork Oh creepy creeping up
there we go sorry about the darkness
okay here sounds like burnt flesh how
would you know was it a rock on egg oh
oh oh yeah uh-huh
ah spider oh oh okay yeah it's in
nothing that loosely closed it yeah
that's better bucket here have a nice
hat hands
ah hey-oh sacrifice my burnt flesh odd
it's just a dog oh it's a dog you do all
right
the dog on the table like so let's see
barrels filled with ashes I was like
burn flash got a bucket here
fire burning dog here okay make the
connection ah oh oh oh wow it's creeping
okay dog
Oh barbed wire Oh put the dog in the
hands oh did I do it
oh that did it yeah that did it that
makes sense oh hello ah no oh hey nope
ah ah oh hey all right
that's something all right go this way
oh this weird oh this is weird
okay oh yeah I love these things come on
shut up let's see you got stuff here oh
that's cool man this game is a lot Wow
oh oh yeah get that Oh gotta do a
sequence all right you know it's you
then you oh yeah oh so smart
come on oh damn it oh then you you oh oh
so smart warm in here yeah shut up okay
yeah now there we go
oh so creepy Oh what the hell is going
on oddly place barrel Wow get him out of
the way how does it oddly placed there
an equally neatly stacked in a corner
very odd Oh does each hand want a barrel
you want a barrel you want a barrel
buddy how about you a barrel is there
another hand another hand somewhere
this is stuck what's this Curt shunk oh
I get it
Oh Oh fine to this circle see you you
yeah this is so gonna be right
Oh am I so smart noose books read ah
maybe all the green circles no there's
four greens
this is like a combo oh oh yeah oh I
don't know what I did but it was genius
oh yeah yeah yeah oh it's most so smart
I don't even realize it Oh more vines
more hands
another saws not stuck yeah oh yeah
would that do
Oh filling the room with blood am I
gonna die now let's see red
Oh Billy those are your hands Billy
your hands are weirdly placed right that
filled with blood that's phenomenal
about this no it's stuck uh blue blue
blue blue all right give me a come out
come out okay what do I do now
let's see okay that filled it with blood
I can't unfill it with blood the bloody
handprints all over it no kid cuz there
I just swam in blood it's my blood where
it's not my blood
my hand with blood okay oh look a little
pale I didn't see anything down there
okay alright I can figure this out
looking at it sequentially again that's
stuck there has to be something down
there past it just has to be nothing
here
ah yeah I mean yeah oh oh all right I'm
not gonna stop playing I'm just gonna
screw it I'm still going go now ah I'll
go jump on you oh so smart
ah no not smart oh yeah
oh this looks interesting whoa what's
going on what's going on oh come here
come here
oh you come here too I'm so great Oh
where'd I go oh this is wrong
oh I can make that totally I just need
to wait for them
oh no I need to go up here okay
look at me Oh Lee jumping skills Oh
Mario training me for this actually you
know what this reminds me of it reminds
me of the dream sequence from Max Payne
any of you ever played that game or
remember that this is a lot like it
really cool Oh
hands come at me bro high five yeah
no-no-no that's what I say
ah oh no oh no aah oh come on
oh I know I know exactly what it is
aah get straight Oh oh boy oh boy
yeah oh come on oh go oh please go oh
why aren't you going to 100
aah god damn it
hey that bland oh oh man I hate that
worm hey that one
Oh salvation
alright Here I am again oh hello boxes
that was interesting yeah okay
Johnny's losing it oh he's so lost it
okay yeah batteries okay oh I know I
really know that's dope it alright
anyway thank you so much for watching
this has been let's play penumbra the
Black Plague I will see you in part 5
don't go anywhere
bye bye